[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Becoming the Next Bill
Nye was a month-long class
that we taught at MIT.
It was a class to
teach students how
to use video to engage an
audience in the things they're
excited about in science
technology, engineering,
and math.
It was workshop
based, very intensive.
We held it every day,
and we had everyone
from undergrads,
freshman, to grad students
coming in from all sorts
of different disciplines.
And they basically had
a chance to learn how
to script, pre-produce, and host
a five-minute YouTube video.
And we had everything
from videos
on how brace's work to how
time travel works to fractals.
And then we took some
of our favorite projects
and turned them into the third
season of MIT's original web
series, Science Out Loud.
We had a teaching
team that was about as
big as our class itself.
We had educators,
producers, hosts.
I think the most valuable
members of our teaching team
were a group of middle
schoolers that we
had come in one day as
our class consultants.
And our students actually had
to pitch their video ideas
to them, because who
better to know the YouTube
landscape better than
a bunch of pre-teens?
So on the MIT
OpenCourseWare site,
you'll pretty much get as close
of an experience to actually
taking the class as
the students did,
because you'll
find the syllabus,
and you'll find all the
assignments, but then
on top of that you'll
find video lectures
where we really try to capture
every single candid moment that
happened in the class.
And then, in particular,
if you're an educator,
there is a special section
called This Course at MIT
where you'll get very specific
instructor insights as
to how we approached designing
this class, how we ran it.
You'll get our confessionals
and sort of insights
into our pedagogical approaches
in teaching a class like this.
The great thing is,
all these materials,
all of our experiences
and resources,
they're all up online on
OpenCourseWare for free.
There's no sign up required.
You can pick and choose
what you want to learn
and you can do it
at your own pace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]